[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
endgame class today I want to walk you
through a whole kind of class of end
games revolving around rook versus rook
plus a rook pawn that is a rook or that
is a pawn that starts on the rook files
the a file or the H file and I wanted to
talk about how many of these positions
are drawn how some of them can in fact
end up being a win and what the
differences are pretty much everything
you need to know about these rook pawns
so let's just dive right into it here I
have the most basic position kind of set
up on the chessboard here this is of
course a draw with best play and the
reason for that is in order to promote
this pawn you need help from the king
there's no way if you just pass back and
forth forever and ever and ever
there's no way for this rook to leave
this pawn in order for the promotion to
happen now there is sort of one major
trick major tactic or what have you that
exists in this position and that trick
totally depends on the positioning of
the black king so this position in
particular is a draw with the King on g7
it turns out there are actually quite
few squares that this King can start on
for the position to be a draw it just so
happens that g7 in h7 are the two on the
Kings side that are able to draw for
black and these are the most common
squares you'll see the King end up on
because usually you know the Kings are
castled Kings side and they're sort of
dealing with the Kings side pawns over
here and when it all simplifies you know
even if there's one pawn is way over
here it's usually easier to get the King
to this position in order to be a draw
it's also draw of course if the King is
very close to the pawn on the queenside
here for example on c6 c7 b6 b7 or or a6
these would all be a draw and in fact
there's actually a sort of surprise two
squares where it could still be a draw
if the King makes it to a 2 and a 1 it
would be a draw down there as well
although that I think by far is is the
most unlikely so why only these squares
is it a drop well that's down to that
one trick that I was talking about here
and that trick is that if this King is
on any of these other squares out in the
middle of the board or even on the back
rank here white can actually remove the
rook from in front of the pawn and is
then able to promote so of course I'll
ask you guys at home to find this trick
if you can chess King has already
anticipated it
if king f7 then rec h8 this is of course
the the basic winning idea for white the
point is you cannot capture this pawn
due to the big skewer now what's the
problem if the black King steps up well
it's much the same in this case though
we just give the check the King has to
move and then we can promote and we end
up in King versus rook once again so
that leaves you thinking well what's the
drawing strategy here for black well of
course you just want to keep the King on
these two squares where it's impossible
to skew of course you know if you try to
come out then we can capture and there's
no skewer or fork here because the rook
defends it as well so you pass back and
forth and then eventually the King does
make it to the B file to attack this
rook here on a3 unfortunately though for
white this is not enough the rook cannot
leave the a file due to the same problem
of this rook simply leaving the a pond
and then promoting so the rook stays in
the a file though potentially coming all
the way up to a six now it's true that
white can come up the board like this
black is sort of forced to just keep
passing but the problem for white is the
second this King touches this pawn black
has moved as far away as possible
and now we'll begin checking the king
and due to the placement of these two
pieces there's actually zero shelter for
the White King anywhere on this entire
chessboard shelter meaning pieces it
could potentially hide behind ways it
could shelter or escape from these
checks by the rook and since there's no
shelter the king would be forced to do
nothing but come all the way back down
whoops we wouldn't want to give that
check once the King comes all the way
back it's not threatening anything
anymore
and so we can just pass and we start
getting repetitions here so this is the
most basic form of this endgame you have
the King over here on g7 or aged seven
just the one pawn left on a seven and
the rook on a eight the White King way
out of play and tonight we're gonna be
taking a look at all the variations of
this very very basic endgame that you'll
kind of end up seeing such as what
happens when the pawn is on a six what
happens if the King gets in front of the
pawn what happens if there's extra pawns
over here on the Kings side so we're
going to take a look at all of those and
see what the key differences are in all
of these and games okay so moving on
intuitively it would make sense that if
White has any extra pawns in this
endgame he would be able to win somehow
and that is almost true turns out if you
have an extra H pawn or in fact an extra
G pawn these positions are still in fact
going to be drawn almost miraculously
for black the reason for that is this
rook is still unable to leave this pawn
here on the Queen side and if you end up
sacrificing this pawn well you're gonna
end up in an even less convincing
endgame where black has the king in
front of the remaining pawn and these
are just well known to be drawn going
back to even the Philidor position if it
were
Jeep on a very simple draw there for
black so the problem is why can't
abandon this pawn or else the endgame
would just be a simple one versus zero
draw so we need this pawn to win which
means we're only winning with the extra
pawn if we can use somehow use it to
dislodge this King from it's two square
shelter here on the Kings side and the
fact is with a G R and H pawn you just
can't do it you can get the pawn all the
way up to age six
but after age six check of course black
is not going to be tempted into
capturing this pawn in allowing or catch
a check with a queen but rather just
king h7 and now rather than move the
King back to g7 as that's now illegal
black is forced to shuffle with the rook
but thankfully for him the same idea
still works
to draw this H pawn or G pawn even would
provide absolutely no shelter to the
king so whether it's a jeep on or an H
pawn these positions are actually still
drawn to the exact same technique we saw
in a very very basic version now the
counter to this is these positions are
always going to be winning for white
rather than drawn and the reason for
that is you can use upon on any of these
files in order to block this king from
one sorry you can use this pawn to
threaten to promote and even on the F
file this would go ahead and work as
well the reason for that being once you
get to f6 the King has to go to h7 and
you can push this pawn up to f7 and
threaten to promote this threat of
promotion is going to be the winning
idea here so the winning moves are
simply you just push this pawn up the
board at your own pace
[Music]
you know however you want to do it we'll
just we'll just let them push and
eventually you get to d7 if we start
giving these checks we just run down the
board we're not worried about this
capture as we can always play Ritchie
eight and Queen and everybody loves the
old queen versus Rick and game but if
you were worried about that you can also
just run run back this way as well so
these positions are always going to be a
win for white black can never of course
take this because of rook b8 and a to
follow so those are the absolute basics
of this rook endgame being all the way
over on the a seven square with with the
pawn if if you have a pawn on the B file
through the F file it's a win if you
have an extra pawn on the G file or the
H file it is a draw so now I wanted to
take a look at a few examples and I got
most of these examples from actually Lee
chess itself it has a pretty intuitive
trainer for these types of end games but
I wanted to talk you through some of
these examples one such example was
sorry
this endgame here this was an endgame
that John Bartholomew actually had
against Michael Taylor I think this was
at a World Open and so what do we have
here well we have a very similar endgame
to the one that we just saw with the
addition of four pawns for each side on
the Kings side here for white and black
actually for both sides and the game g6
was played King h2 King g7 a7 King h7 so
now we are perfectly in this position
where we have the a7 pawn and we have
this position with extra pawns on the
board so using what we've learned so far
I want you guys at home to try and find
a winning method here
for white try and find some way to make
progress in these and
in this endgame with this extra a
7-point what do you guys think what do
you guys think
how can white make progress in this
endgame
what's the winning method here does
anybody have any ideas teenage 3 G 3 F 4
okay and what if black ignores its what
if black just continues passing yeah he
takes that forward G takes up 4 E 5 that
would make a past epon butts captures
are not forced
and chess King will actually see a
similar method to yours shown in the
next game there's actually an even
easier way to to breakthrough here for
white so let's talk about some
differences here compared to the first
position it seems like nobody has seen
the idea used in this game just yet but
a few differences here kingi one and run
over to the Kings side King g3 came to
e6 okay so these are some good ideas of
course in the basic position when the
King gets over to b6 it gets checked
forever and ever and ever and the King
has no choice but to run all the way
back to the second rank now that's not
going to be the case here in this case
there is actually some shelter on the
board provided by these four pawns so
after we get checked and checked and
checked forever we are in fact able to
run to the e6 square or even potentially
the the e7 square now let's go ahead and
get that on the board so as white we can
go as far as we want so let's actually
see as played in the game the King gets
all the way up here now in the game rook
a six was played by black which is
perfectly fine King b5 rook a 1 so from
here how do we want to actually go ahead
and and make the last amount of progress
by white it's true that you can just
kind of run to the e6 square but what
does that actually attain for you
what are you attaining by getting the e6
I'm not so sure I see it so go ahead you
guys at home sit and think in this
position try and find try and find the
way to to win this position with white
what's the key
finishing idea here
chess King says ah he's afraid King e6
g3 f4 okay so you guys seem to be sold
on this g3 f4 idea with the point being
that you can eventually win this epon
and you guys are actually being a little
bit too clever I think this idea may
actually work in this position it does
work in the next position we're gonna
take a look at and I don't see a real
reason why it wouldn't work here as well
but there's actually an even simpler way
to do it in this case so let's say you
go ahead and get this position you know
maybe this check is given you know King
e6 rook back you could go for this type
of business with this stuff
and the point being you want to play at
four and then all of a sudden you you're
taking this a pawn right you might run
into some difficulties of your opponent
trying to play a move like g5 and all of
a sudden things are still a little bit
unclear but there's an even easier way
even easier way king b6 rook b8 so as
soon as you step to b6 of course this
check is going to come on the board this
is the draw that we were looking at you
know you just get checked and then as
soon as your King touches the pawn it's
forced to run away so not quite give up
the pawn this is King Lear and that is
actually exactly correct here so king c6
was played in the game rook a2 by John
Bartholomew's opponent and the key idea
here is that you're able to transpose
into a winning King and pawn endgame
this is a huge downside to being forced
to leave the King back on the seventh
rank on g7 and h7 is in positions like
these this King is active enough to
simply win this endgame so the g3 and f4
ideas are very very clever and they
might work out but they are slightly
more complex than the wind played in
this game which is just to play the move
rook d8 in this
after king c6 you play rook d8 and the
game is immediately ending rook takes a
seven is absolutely forced if you try to
give checks like these I can just run
away over to the e8 square I'm promoting
anyways so Rick Texas have an absolutely
forced and this allows rook d7 check and
this is now in fact a fork rook takes t7
King takes d7 and this King upon endgame
is quite simply hopeless nothing to be
done here we can even just play g3 I
think you takes and step over you do get
out run eventually I believe I made this
like way more difficult on myself than
it needed to be but we went eventually
it's a kingdom pawn endgame with her
King on the seventh rank and your King
on the seventh rank we're going to win
made that a little bit harder probably
much much simpler was to just capture
this guy to capture this guy sorry it's
being a little bit silly but we got
there in the end so the key idea was
this rip d8 to d7 check idea trading off
the rooks and going into a totally
winning
endgame from there so well done King
Lear who saw it donkey puncture donkey
puncher actually saw it as well this was
the key idea used in this game but let's
go ahead and move on though there is
definitely more chest to go over here
jumping into this rook endgame we saw a
similar story in this endgame I'm going
to skip ahead a little bit to the key
position we had F 3 H 3 rook e8
King g6 a 6 rook a to and so in this
position I am going to ask you many
questions because I am a horribly
horribly mean person number one what's
the evaluation of this position is it a
win or is it a draw I will give you the
hint black is not winning here but is it
a win or a draw is not such an easy
question to answer
and from there if you think it's winning
what's the winning move if you think
it's a draw well prove it prove it how
do you draw against White's ideas so
this one might take you guys just a
second here but use that knowledge that
we gained from these first few examples
here white is winning this is Sofia or
sippy so I don't know so how is white
winning
so Neil agrees everybody thinks white is
winning perhaps perhaps you guys are
looking at this little number one down
here I see I see that you can see this
little number one but is this position
winning not did white win this position
but is this position winning all right
chess King has suggested a line that
loses by force I was hoping someone
would suggest this you play the move a
seventh black is not going to play the
move King f7 said they're going to play
f4 check in to rip g2 checkmate and you
were going to be very very sad so a7 not
the winning attempt okay someone now in
the chat with characters and own
language I do not speak is suggesting h4
to begin with which is also likely very
similar to chess King's idea cracks
Miller is taking the bait and now says
draw but you guys have arrived at the
key variation the key variation is h4
this is the winning attempt for white so
the question arises this is a winning
attempt does it actually win if it does
how if it doesn't how this is the idea
right
so take a second and think about it here
think about it what are blacks choices
hello Martin from Norway donkey puncher
says after g4 I think black drawers
okay so donkey puncture has go ahead
gone ahead and joined the draw team g4
by black draws us as Alexi
so Alexi has some ideas here good to see
you Lexi so you guys have arrived at the
key try for black doesn't win due to f4
check says cracks Miller so none of you
are suggesting the move G takes h4 okay
I mean obviously this is the first move
that you look at and this was actually
the move played in the game so why is G
takes h4 wrong this is in fact a poor
choice by by black in this case King teh
stage 4 was played in the game
rook a 4 check King g3 King f6 and now
how do you win here by by white
how does white win in this position and
and why let's start with this one stuck
in a puddle says a seven but okay you
guys aren't telling me why why this is
winning you're suggesting moves still
how is white winning what's the winning
idea
okay you guys are still just suggesting
moves like okay f4 is a move a7 is a
move but how do you win
okay so I think I'm seeing a couple
people suggesting bringing the king in
front of the pawns and this is the right
idea so I'll give you this if you play
the move a seven and black plays the
move King g7 and okay you start with F
for black passes forever eventually this
is going to be a winning attempt you
come to be three okay one now you can
come up the board okay five King before
and here you get all the way to e6 and
now after rook a5 you do in fact win
this position with the killer move King
f6 and this is the problem now for black
with the F pawn on f5 King f6 puts black
into a total zoogs Vong so of course
q g7 is now illegal you cannot keep this
rook on the fifth rank to defend your
pawn so you have to move and then we
take the F pawn and as we know having an
extra pawn on any of these files is
going to be a win it's only not a win
when it's a G or an H pawn so this
position totally winning for white you
just push this guy up the board as we've
seen before and nothing to be done about
this pawn so this is the winning idea
but the move a seven actually draws the
game it is critically important that
white plays the move f4 as played in the
game here if you start with a 7 guess
what f4 check King g4 King g7 now all of
a sudden it's not possible for you to
take away the g7 square and attack f4 at
the same time and this means that black
is happy to pass back and forth with
these two moves until the end of time so
the position even after G takes h4 was
in fact a draw however there's no need
to go in for this sort of shady business
after h4 you guys are correct the move
for is much more easily drawing and the
idea of course is that after a seven we
dropped the King back to g7 you see it
takes takes takes and now white is left
with the wrong pawn this H pawn of
course not enough to win the game as we
have seen in the past and if white goes
for something like f4 well this isn't
going to quite work out either you can't
really bring the King around a six it's
now all of a sudden you are going to
have to pay attention to this Jeep on so
we can't do that winning method that we
saw after G takes h4 and f4 so a really
interesting position here in this game
between Michael hawk structure and
Severn Appa it I don't know why I even
tried to say the names but in the game
f4 was not played King f6 played and now
f4 by white and this game is over so
well done to those of you who found this
idea of bringing the King in front of
the pawns but the really key point is at
the end you take away both the g7 and VF
v square and this is how this position
is winning so okay I've got one more to
torch you guys with before we move on to
something slightly different
still with the rook pawns this is a
position from a game of Boris Spassky
against eugenio Toure of course in this
position Spassky has the white pieces
and it looks very very very similar to
the John Bartholomew position but the
same winning idea does not work here the
reason for that is of course this pawn
is on g7 and not on g6 what does this
mean this means if you get your king to
c6 and play rook d8 Rick takes a 7
rook d7 is not check so you cannot force
the rooks off the board now I don't want
to spend too much time on this one here
because you guys already very very
astutely have found the winning idea for
white in this position of course you
start with this move g3 okay to check
King g1 King g6 and
f4 is a great great idea
of course if it takes f4 were to be
played we would play G takes f 4 and now
we can force through a past epon and as
we all know a past epon is enough to win
these positions it's only the G and H
pawns and that are not enough so of
course black is not going to capture it
in this pun and said king f7 is played
if f e5 f e5 quick note here about King
up seven king f7 in this case is going
to be playable even though it's not one
of our two main squares the reason of
course being once again this pawn on g7
provides a little bit of shelter for the
black King so you're able to go to f7
here so from now I'll ask you guys once
again what do you think the winning idea
is here for white see if you can do it
King Lear says g4x clam question mark
I don't think g4 is actually going to be
the way in this case I guess your idea
is you want to try to play h5 h6 but
unfortunately the black king can
actually come to the g6 square as well
and your your pod on age six is not
going to be touched so let's let's take
a look for example each tribe let's say
g3 you play h6 King g6 is actually going
to be the key move here and we're not
going to touch your pawn we're just
going to play the King back to h7 then
threatening to capture and this this one
should be a draw King edge 7 key idea
takes takes and we are back in draw
territory g4 is an interesting idea
though
interesting idea King just comes up and
takes the e pawn so let me ask you a
question then using your knowledge from
the previous position how do you take
the e pawn when black can plant a rook
on the a5 square how do you solve this
problem right how do you take the e pawn
when rook a5 is just going to be
defending this is the key here
is there a difference of the ponies on a
six we're gonna be taking a look at
positions with the pawn on a six right
after this you're a bit ahead of me here
just a bit ahead of me let him take a
seven give up a seven well how do you
want to give up on a seven because if
you give up on a seven with something
like Rick h8 takes takes this position
is is just going to be a draw three
versus two on the Kings side is
generally always a draw and it's not
super super difficult to to attain so
these positions tend to be a draw so
I'll give you a hint you guys have the
right idea with bringing the King over
to try to attack the e pawn but my
question still remains how do you ever
capture the e pawn after black plays
rook a5 to defend it so this is the
current question bring the King to d5
rook at five check King d6 zoogs Vung so
this is the right idea by Beltran
actually so you bring the King over and
we'll just play through the game moves
as Boris did it well enough and as he
often does King d5 or okay five check
King d6 and this is in fact going to be
sug
so this King now cannot stay on f7 this
rook has to stay in the a file has to
stay in the fifth-ranked to fund pawn so
king g6 is forced and now after King e6
you can go King h7 but now you're just
asking for King f5 when finally this
King is out playing both rook and King
and there's nothing left to be done if
g6 check King f6 same problem the King
can't move the rook can't move and this
is a total zoogs bunk and white is
winning the pawn a very similar idea to
the one that we saw previously with this
thug okay
so these are a few of the winning ideas
with the pawn already on ace
as we see here so when you have these
other ponds on the kingside as in these
this case here in the case of John
Bartholomew's game you have these
various winning ideas John Bartholomew
and going for this rook d8 with riff d7
check to follow trading off the rooks
and giving up the a pawn in this game
Boris Spassky coming up with g3 at for
creating this weakness on e5 and then
putting the black king into Zhuge Vung
in order to force the black rook to shy
away from defending the e pawn and get
that winning position so those are two
really key winning ideas other winning
ideas in general creating any past pawn
that's not on the G or the H file is
enough to win these games which is also
why G 3 and F 4 works here as well so I
think I robbed you of seeing the end of
this game king b6 let's see no I guess
this is how the game went yeah this is
exactly how the game went no Rick a1 was
played not King h7 then king e5 king of
7 king of 5 rock a5 check be v g6 check
King you four and here black did just
end up resigning east 6 check is
unstoppable
well actually King g7e 60 78 is
unstoppable and Spassky is totally
totally winning here so those are some
key variations with this pawn on a7
hopefully you feel like you learned
something there now moving on we have
the pawn on a6 and this is going to be a
position known as the Bankura position
named after van kuren
who came up with this position so what's
the difference here well of course with
the pawn on a6 everything changes why
wouldn't it so let's see what happens if
black plays the same way that black has
been playing previously just passing why
it comes over to the Queen side and the
black Kirk escapes and King comes up
will pass again and then as soon as we
touch the pawn will start giving checks
well what's the difference here the
difference is king c6 king b6
and whoops turns out there is shelter
when the pawn is on a six this is going
to be enough shelter for the King to
survive so what can we do about it
what can we do about it here does
anybody know the drawing technique here
in this van career position does anybody
already know it named after mr. position
close named after mr. van Kura of course
so what's the drawing technique for
black in this case does anybody already
know this one's much less intuitive than
then the first one not seeing a lot from
the chat room perhaps this one is new
territory for our esteemed chat members
I'll crush says ah this one so not a new
territory for him but maybe a quick
refresher on the basic of Ankara rook
comes to e6 for flexibility kind of yes
I don't know if I would say flex
flexibility necessarily but this is in
fact and going to be the correct idea
just keep the king trapped on the first
two ranks until the pawn goes up well
not necessarily right if the King comes
over here you can see two king g6 king
b2 if you try to run away now well all
of a sudden you can't come back this is
the issue you can't come back and then
next thing you know this pawn is
queening so that won't quite work
in Korea it's VA n see you are a
use side checks so this is of course the
idea I'll on La Vie has it this is why
we want to bring the rook to the sixth
rank so the idea of keeping the behind
the pawn is that we make it so that this
rook has no flexibility right the sort
can't move out of the way but the other
idea in the position with the pawn on a7
is that we can check from behind and the
king will have no shelter in this case
the King does have shelter on the a7
square so that's why in this position
well it's way to move in this position
the key idea is to step out from behind
the pawn now if a 7 we can switch ideas
go back to behind it and we have the
same drawing technique we saw before and
if not well all of a sudden we come to
the 6th rank so now white is left in
this awkward position where one this
rook cannot leave the protection of this
pawn it has to stay protecting it if y
ever dares to push this pawn we
immediately step behind the pawn same
drawing technique as before and then
lastly from the 6th rank the other
advantage is when this King comes up the
board we can step all the way over here
and all of a sudden we have a new idea
in this position in particular of
checking from the side so we saw that
black or that white has shelter when we
check from behind but when we check from
the side of the board once again there
is nowhere for this King to hide so
check check check check this King has
nowhere to go and as soon as it touches
us we can run away once again so this is
the critical idea for for black in order
to draw these positions now if you're
worried at all about this King coming to
this square
don't be the King actually is no more
help on 7th rank than it is on any of
these ranks towards advancing the
spawn if a seven we still just step
behind king c7 it's not in time to get
back to the pawn we can still check from
behind now if you ever find yourself in
this position and you play the move rook
d6 this of course would be a critical
critical mistake you have to check from
at least the e-file in order for it to
be a draw so the e or the F file are
where you want to be checking from the
sides the other files don't always work
the reason being now we can play king c7
sorry it not King c7 King b7 king c6
this trick is attacked and all of a
sudden we can step out of the way in the
king is close enough that it is no
longer going to be a draw versus when we
check on this rank one more time just
for fun
well King d7 here we just stay on the
sixth rank sorry excuse me confuse
myself for a second so the D file
doesn't work because when we check the
King comes to b6 when we check again
King comes to b7 and now we would be
forced to check again and the King can
go to c6 attacking our rook removing it
from the sixth rank whereas on the
e-file when the King steps to this
square we can check here and when the
King steps back we can still step to the
sixth rank as for the reason the H or
the G files won't work well that's
pretty intuitive as well the reason is
you are unable to check on the seventh
rank because your king would be in the
way now if our King were here now the
mover ik g6 would still be enough to
draw so this is the van kuren
position you bring this king or this
rook to the sixth rank and you check
from the side in this case
so yes attacking the pawn from the site
so yeah I'll crush or for anybody just
joining we spent kind of the first 40
minutes of the lecture looking at
positions with the pawn on whoops nook
with the pawn already on a 7 the various
winning attempts that you have they're
using other pawns on the board now we're
looking at the banker position and
trying to understand a little bit more
about that moving right along here I'm
in Korea it's VA and see you are a
banker moving on let's take a look at a
position from a game between Magnus
Carlsen and Levon Aronian this is from
excuse me let me check the sink filled
Cup I knew it in 2014 so played right
here in st. Louis and they got kind of a
version of this end game that I wanted
to take you guys through so in this
position white is obviously up upon in
this case the a pawn black played the
move c5 we got King III rook over it to
d4 rook a six King G 785 rook a4 and we
have this position on the board so what
do you guys think the evaluation of this
endgame is obviously we have the a pawn
but also and we have this G pawn and
this H pawn against the C pawn in the H
pawn for for black here so it's not
entirely clear at first glance which of
these basic rules basic positions we've
encountered so far are going to be
relevant here fast word of the end yeah
we don't care that that early opening
middle game stuff I teach other classes
for those this is going to be the
endgame class oh gosh
confidently says draw exclamation point
perhaps he's looking at this little
number done this little number it's so
deceptive it's almost always wrong about
the evaluation in the position they
always mess these ones up somehow
but yeah the Sinquefield Cup 2014 here
we are
storm didn't even realize I was doing
the lesson today yeah every Monday and
Wednesday back on schedule now I'm doing
lectures here at the club so generally
these positions should kind of be a draw
right where you just have the one a pond
we have seen that you can we have this
van Kura stuff that works out but in
this case it's actually not going to be
so simple g4 was played in the game and
now using his knowledge of the van
current position Levon Aronian came up
with a very interesting move
unfortunately for LaVon it's not going
to be a drawing move in this case came
up with the move age five and after age
five Magnus captures on h5 and using
knowledge of van current position he
knew that having an H pawn does not
change the evaluation of the van cur
position it just doesn't because of
course the king can still stay on h7 you
can't force it off of age seven and
we'll do the same business with the rook
on the sixth rank in the same business
of coming back to a six if you ever push
the pawn we've seen those positions
before so white now has two H pawns and
this is the idea but as the game
continued we saw rook a3 check King F or
C for King D for C three note if you
don't do this and you start going a
little crazy trying to get the rook over
you can't immediately go for the van
kuren position because white is still
currently controlling in the sixth rank
so c3 instead is a very natural move by
black keeping this pawn on the board now
King d3 King age seven and now I want
you to find White's best winning try in
this position why it's best winning try
here
and I don't want you to tell me if it is
a win or not or if it's still a draw
somehow how does white win this position
mendel says King C - Sunil says King D 3
that's where the king or D is
so try and provide some justification
try and provide some justification
what can be done here for white your
goal is to avoid the banker opposition
Rick a7 check has been suggested I'm not
sure for a k7 check changes the
evaluation of the position but it's not
really a winning try you guys are still
just suggesting only one moves but can
you tell me the reason why do you want
to play these moves Rick g6 c6h6 these
are all one moves one one move
suggestions here come up with an idea
okay you guys don't seem to be getting
getting it Rick a 7 a 6h 6 rook g7 okay
that's a lot of moves you're playing
there so Rick a seven check we'll take a
look at Rick at 7:00 so Rick a 7
I think I'm going to go to h6 rather
rather than rather than g8 allowing you
to play aged six and now play a6 King
takes 85 I think I'm just in time to get
back to where I need to be if you do go
for this a7 business so we're k7 check
I'm not so sure is getting the job done
now let me tell you the movement that
magnus carlsen plate magnus carlsen
played the move age six turns out this
move is a dead draw of course h6 massive
blunder drawing the chess game by these
principles that we know of the banker
position so some of you did have the
right move but have yet to see anybody
tell me why it's the correct move why is
king - C - the only move that wins the
game in this position does anybody get
it does anybody understand why king c2
is the only move that wins
hello to chest bass Arabia don't know if
that's the real chest base based in
Arabia but appreciate you watching the
idea is to try to avoid the rook moving
to the other side so that is exactly
right so thus what is the drawing move
after h6 what did Levon Aronian play to
draw the game after h6 no it's not cuz
it forces the rook to babysit it's not
that at all
this pawn doesn't matter so much anymore
it doesn't matter so much see two checks
each you checks you to check see to
check with b3 or it takes h3 no zombie
person zombie person thank you so much
zombie person as the correct move the
correct move is rook b3 this is why king
c2 was the only move because rook b3 now
is achieving in the van current position
we can still play king c2 this rook will
come to b5 and we have this same idea
except just one file shifted up the
board King takes c3 does not matter and
as we now see in the game Levon Aronian
is able to draw sitting on this six
drink giving checks when the King steps
close well in this case the fifth rank
and these pawns push up the board it
doesn't matter
no shelter for this King
eventually we do see the pawn step to a
six and now our rook steps to b6 and
this is the draw this is the draw that
we have so comfortably seen before so
way back here way back here
king of c2 was the only move and the
reason it's the only move is because it
prevents the van curb position it
prevents the move rook b3 and due to the
placement of the black rook and we have
no comfortable way to get out from
behind this a pawn if you play the move
okay for then King takes c3 is going to
be winning if you still trying to get
out from behind the pawn now all of a
sudden you're running into a problem of
I believe the move rook c6 you are not
in time to to play this way now if you
go to b5 all of a sudden a6 and wait a
second there's no banker position when
the rook is already on the sixth rank
and this is just going to be a winning
position for white note that after h6
rook b3 if white tries the same what do
we do well we can step back to a3 I
believe and now if a 6-hour pawn is
still on the board actually and I think
this is going to end up being relevant
here as you cannot push this guy up you
cannot push this King up or leave this
pawn to run and there's nothing really
doing here for either side if you give
this check we can take and the circus
attacked and what's this oh yeah we have
achieved very very similar stuff this is
still live and correct position so very
instructive draw here from Levon Aronian
showing how even the world champion can
mess up these end games and very
important move in this position King c2
would have won the game for Magnus
keeping this rook out of the B 3 square
showing that this stuff still gets
tricky even at the top top levels please
analyze h4 into the King c2 it's going
to be the same business here
rook b3 is
the drawing idea and no matter what you
do will step to be five and it's going
to be more of the same in fact I think
h4 was eventually played in the game
anyways and this is just going to be
similar to what you would get playing it
immediately remember this from
commentary chess King with a long memory
I make the 2014 commentary it's knowing
this even necessary in a Scholastic
level everyone sucks so nobody will know
how to win
well now you will know how to win and
isn't necessary to remember I mean I
don't know if it's the right way to be
thinking about it you know I like
knowing this stuff
examining this stuff because I find it
really interesting and I like knowing
things about chess is it useful yes it
can be useful it does show up in games
as we see here is it the most useful
thing to your chest improvement probably
not probably this is going to be one
that doesn't show up super super often
in your games if it does some even if it
does sometimes but it's it's good to
know things about chess it helps you
become a more well-rounded chess player
I think all right I have just one more
example to show you guys with the last
five minutes here we do have a very
similar thing that occurred in the
clutch chess event which is what made me
want to go over this lecture this was
another position from a game between
Jeffries Jung and Magnus Carlsen Jeffery
in fact had the white pieces here and
now we are going to learn the final idea
the final rule involved with with these
rook pawns so in this position King age
six was played rook g3 by Geoffrey Zhang
was the attempt to get his King s to be
able to escape DirectX h2 King a3 or a
cage fighter King h5 and eventually
Geoffrey captures this pawn on a4 so
what do we have here everyone now we
have finally a different situation the
pawn is very very far back but our
King is in front of it and it is going
to stay in front of it so what is the
evaluation of this position everyone
what is the evaluation here okay it also
wins the last position as per stockfish
I'm not convinced that it does stockfish
can't evaluate these things wrong but
[Music]
maybe maybe it does win as well but the
principled idea is king c2c bukhara says
draw and that is absolutely correct here
I don't want to spend too much time we
are running a bit short but this
position is a draw and now this is
probably the easiest of the variations
to calculate basically and the idea is
if the king is can get to the e-file or
closer it's a draw if the King gets cut
off on the F file or further away then
it's a win so a huge mistake
would be to play the move King f6 when
rookie four I think might be winning
for example we push this pawn forward
and then we would be winning I think
this is actually going to be a special
case though where this isn't winning
because we can play the move rook d5 no
wait wait a second wait a second rook c2
and rook c6 and the idea is we are just
in time with rookie six to get our King
over but in general in general I'm sorry
the rule is if the King is this far away
or more and the pawn is significantly
far advanced then it is a draw but if
the King can just get to this efile then
it is going to be a draw so in the game
we saw King to see for rook c4 and the
King gets all the way over to the D file
in fact which definitely makes this a
draw in the game Geoffrey push this pawn
all the way up the board but we see here
now the problem is the King gets to the
C file and the
King has no way to get out from behind
the pawn if it ever tries King v8 and
the black king is the one that will be
getting in front of the pawn to blockade
for a draw so let's take a quick look at
what happens if the King does get stuck
on the e-file for example if we get
stuck here why is this still going to be
a draw well let's examine and let white
get all the way up the board and this is
pretty difficult to stop actually so
King up
rokay to pawn up or could be to check
King here something like this normally
Brooke here can you six pawn up Kenny
seven King up rook B to pawn up so why
is this a draw
what is the drawing idea here well the
point of the King having to be on the F
file or further away is that there is
only one way for white to escape with
the King out from in front of the pot
and that way is to get this rook somehow
to the b7 square we get the rook to the
b7 square then we can win this position
by playing King v8 and queening our pond
also of course the b8 square would
suffice because then we could move the
rook out and then do similar things so
what happens if we try that well if we
go all the way this way
King d6 here King art sorry let's go
Rick h8 so we get to b8 King c7 rook b8
we succeed in forcing this rook away but
as soon as we step here suddenly we are
in the position in the game where we see
that the king is enough to keep this guy
out we give this check King b7 you try
to step out suddenly same issues as
before
so no way to win now what happens if the
Kings are one file further back
well now we get to win by bringing the
rook here check and here we are just in
time so once again the rule I'm going to
leave you guys with if the King can get
to the e-file or closer in these end
games with the White King in front of
the pawn it is a draw that is stuck on
the F file or further away then it is a
win for white in general just a brief
last rule to leave you off with and yet
another type of position with rook
versus real plus or rook pawn so that
just about does it for this endgame
lecture thank you all very much for
joining me
hopefully you feel like you have a
fairly complete understanding of all of
these end games involving the rook pawns
they're a lot trickier than you then you
might give them credit for at first but
I think this more or less covers a
really really broad spectrum of the
types of end games you can end up in
with these extra a pawns for H pawns
beyond that and that does it for
tonight's YouTube lectures if you're
watching live be sure to head over to
the twitch channel for analytes excuse
me analyze your games if you're just
watching the video that does it for me
here tonight
once again my name is Caleb Denby and I
will see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you